If you're struggling to understand
Hertzberg's theory of motivation,
then this video is made for you.
So Hertzberg's theory of motivation
suggested that there are two set of distinct factors
that influence employee satisfaction and motivation
in the workplace,
and those factors were hygiene factors
and a motivator factors.
So starting off without hygiene factors,
if they are present,
they prevent employee dissatisfaction,
but if they are present,
they do not necessarily
lead to increased levels of motivation
or job satisfaction,
which are mainly are extrinsic factors
such as an adequate salary,
job security
and a clean work environment.
Whereas our motivator factors,
they contribute towards employees job satisfaction
and their motivation.
And these are mainly centered around our
intrinsic factors
where our employees are motivated
by self accomplishment and personal growth in work,
which can be achieved by job empowerment,
increase levels of responsibility
and challenging and meaningful work.
Let me know in the comments below
of any companies that you know who implement
Herzberg's variant of motivation.